um could you explain the difference
between zaka and
zakat as far as the difference between
zakat and zakat is concerned number one
as we discussed earlier a few days back
that zakat means to purify to cleanse to
increase and Zak means a purifying
charity for the breaking of fast
specifically the first is purification
of your wealth and and surplus am MOD
Etc that is zakat zakat is purification
of the breaking of the fast mean
purification of the fast you have kept
from the minor sin we have committed or
the obscene talks or the empty talks
that's number one number two that
zakat is mainly given
on the wealth it's meant for purifying
your wealth your Surplus wealth if it is
above the nisab level as far as zakat is
concerned it is meant for purification
of your fast from empty talks from
obscene talks all the minor sins that
you might have done in the month of
Ramadan while fasting so it purifies
that number
three zakat should be given by every
Muslim who has a surplus wealth above
the nisab level and the nisab level for
normal things with the gold silver
wealth Etc is equivalent to 85 g of gold
and and 5 995 G of
silver if it's cattle then we discussed
earlier that sheep more than 40 have to
give one sheep etc etc for the farm
produce if without irrigation it is 10%
with irrigation 5% Etc so basically it
should begin with those people who are
Saab who have extra wealth Surplus
wealth as far as Zak is concerned every
Muslim whether's slave or free young or
old man or woman should give
zakat unless he is very poor or mine or
doesn't have the provision this is the
third difference fourth difference is
that the recipient of zakat there are
eight categories as mentioned in chapter
number 9 verse number 60 the poor
people the
needy those involved in collecting of
Zak those hearts are coming towards
Islam number five Arab freeing of slaves
number six is the debtors number seven
is in the way of Allah and the eighth is
sail the wayer these are the eight
categories who can receive zakat as far
as the recipient of Z is concerned
mention of Abu da volume number two book
of zakat Hadith number 1605 it should be
given to the poor people so the
recipient are only the very poor and the
Miskin people who don't have the
provision of food that's the fourth
difference the fifth difference is that
the time should be given zakat can be
given any time of the year though it has
to be given when you have Surplus weth
for one full year that's the time it is
due but it can be given any time of the
year people prefer the month of Ramadan
being a blessed month but it can be
given any time of the year as far as Zak
it is limited time you should give it
before the
Salah preferably before the poor people
go to pray Salah or maximum permission
is eeve of or one two or three days
before Eid that's it so limited 3 4 days
time where can be given whereas zakat
can throughout the year and the last
difference is as far as zakat is
concerned it should be given in the form
of food that we mentioned rice wheat
Bali raisin dat Etc but zakat can be
given any form in the form of money it
can be gold it can be silver it can be
animal so the equivalent amount can be
any form these are the major six
differences between Zak and Zak well Dr
Zaki thank you very much once again